today on the matt walsh show the trans
cult has a powerful ally in the courts
and more and more we're seeing courts
take custody away from parents who will
not affirm their children as trans today
we'll talk about one especially
harrowing and tragic example of this
also joe biden continues his transition
into a ventriloquist dummy we're
starting to see some early primary
polling data and it's a hilarious
disaster for the democrats pete boudejij
says his feelings are hurt that not
everyone agrees with his definition of
marriage cnn claims that biden can save
all life on earth with an executive
order and in our daily cancellation
camila harris unveils the latest most
cutting-edge innovation in the field of
virtue signaling all of that and more
today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
the supreme court decision to overturn
roe is a huge albeit long overdue step
in the right direction but there's still
a long way to go to rid our country of
abortion completely many companies are
bowing to the woke mob by donating
pro-choice causes and candidates or
reimbursing their employees travel
expenses so that they can go and uh get
an abortion if they live in a pro-life
state
um
that's what's going on and what if i
told you that if you're currently on a
phone plan with one of the major
carriers you might be supporting these
companies and their pro-abortion agendas
without even knowing it just when you
pay your monthly phone bill don't let
abortionists use your money to fund
policies that you don't believe in
switch to charity mobile instead charity
mobile is a pro-life pro family cell
phone company that sends five percent of
your monthly plan price to the pro-life
charity of your choice you don't have to
compromise on values or good phone
service you get it all
in the same company with charity mobile
charity mobile offers the latest 5g
phones no device or service contracts
great nationwide coverage and live
customer service base right here in the
usa the fight for the right to life
continues and pro-life causes need your
support you can help by simply switching
your phone service to charity mobile
today call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com mention offer code
walsh to redeem a free cell phone offer
today also that's charitymobile.com and
offer code walsh
we know that the trans agenda is
anti-truth anti-reality anti-science but
that alone is is not what makes it so
harmful i mean flat earthers are also
anti-reality and yet we don't spend a
lot of time worrying that our kids will
get sucked into that cult what makes the
trans agenda so dangerous and
destructive is that the truths it
militates against are the most basic
truths of all it seeks to warp a
person's understanding of
themselves of their own identity it's
one thing to have wild misconceptions
about the shape of the earth
it's another to have wild misconceptions
about yourself your body your identity
your your place in the world
but the trans cult does something else
too which many other cults before it
have done though none with anywhere near
this level of success
it attacks and destabilizes the family
one of the many truths that it opposes
is the truth of the nuclear family it
hates
the family because that institution the
family attests so powerfully to the true
nature of the human person and of the
two sexes
it also hates the family because
children raised in stable families
protected and guided by parents in a
loving and sturdy marriage
are much more difficult to reach
and indoctrinate
they're not impervious they're not
impervious to brainwashing but they are
significantly shielded against it
a family provides a child with an anchor
he is secured he's sheltered protected
the groomers then have to take away this
anchor blow up the family
leaving kids unmoored and unprotected
vulnerable
like like a baby deer wandering through
the forest easy prey for the wolves this
is why the groomer spent so much time
and so much effort trying desperately to
to place this wedge in between the child
and the parent this is why we hear about
so many schools that have policies of
intentionally hiding a student's lgbt
self-identification from parents and
even even after all the backlash and
outrage over these sorts of policies
still many teachers continue to engage
in this kind of predatory behavior and
brag about it openly here's just the
latest example from this week
if you as a teacher have a student come
to you and tell you that they are
gay part of the lgbtq community
whether they are
looking into transitioning anything like
that but they don't want their parents
to know yet
the question on the news was
as a teacher is it your responsibility
or as a school is it your responsibility
to inform the parents
of what their child is going through
on the news they all said yes it is the
schools the teachers the counselors
due diligence to let these parents know
what the kids are going through
as a teacher i disagree
i did have a student come and tell me
this last year that she was gay
she did not want her mom to know and i
respected her wishes
now that teacher like so many others
wants to have intimate knowledge of a
child that the child's parents
do not have
this is a classic cult tactic it's right
from the cult handbook the recruiter of
the cult seeks to form a bond with the
recruit that supersedes any bond they
have with anybody else including and
especially family members
take that crowbar and pry the child away
from the parent that's the idea and
increasingly
the prying is taking more aggressive and
invasive forms often involving the
courts acting as the the crowbar
in my film what is a woman we heard the
story of course of a father in canada
who was sent to jail
and lost custody of his daughter because
he wouldn't affirm her as a boy for
simply insisting that his daughter is
his daughter
that she is his daughter and not his son
that the girl he helped conceive and
raise still exists
he lost everything
this sort of thing happens frequently in
canada and will become even more
frequent with the recent passage of an
anti-conversion therapy law so-called
which declares it an illegal form of
conversion therapy for anyone including
parents to refuse to use biologically
incorrect pronouns for a child
if you do that if you call a girl she
and she wants to be called he then you
are now engaging in conversion therapy
it's against the law
your criminal will put you in jail and
take your kids away
but it's also starting to happen in the
u.s
now have already been well-known cases
like the jeff younger case that you've
probably heard about um even before that
there were cases like one in ohio for
example where two parents in this case
their two parents still married
lost custody of their daughter because
they refused to allow her to medically
transition into a boy
the judge legally kidnapped the girl
and and gave custody to the grandparents
that she judge sylvia hendon trusted
would facilitate the child drugging and
mutilation now that happened back in
2018
and it's only going to become more
common now as as time continues
which means we're going to see more and
more stories like that of janette cooper
now janette cooper is a 44 year old
woman whose a tragic tale was
highlighted this week by journalist
kelsey bolar of the independent women's
forum on the iwb on the iwf website
she tells tells the story of how cooper
who's the mother to a 12 year old girl
also by the way a lifelong progressive
democrat
by no means is this like a conservative
with an axe to grind ideologically
it's a progressive democrat woman and
mother
lost custody of her daughter because
unlike her ex-husband
she wouldn't affirm her daughter's
deluded idea that she was really a boy
reading now from the article says
jeanette cooper never imagined she'd
lose custody of her child the 44 year
old lifelong educator always considered
herself a loving and responsible mother
to her daughter sophia
but when at age 12 sophia suddenly
claimed to be transgender jeannette was
skeptical sophia had never exhibited
signs of gender dysphoria in fact sophia
exhibited many more traditionally
feminine behaviors and preferences than
jeannette ever had
to janette it didn't make sense but
sophia insisted not only that she was
trans but that she was unsafe around
jeanette
what followed was an almost kafka-esque
series of court proceedings and therapy
sessions in which jeanette's ex-husband
lawyers therapist and other individuals
in institutions supposedly concerned
with sofia's best interests work to
erode jeannette's most basic parenting
rights
nearly three years later jeannette can't
even visit with the daughter she loves
she lives less than 10 minutes away but
can only communicate with sophia by u.s
mail
all because she insists that sophia is a
girl
now from here we're told
the whole story about how jeannette and
her husband divorced in 2015 now at
first jeannette was as very often
happens was awarded almost full custody
of her daughter she had her daughter six
days a week
but then one day at the age of 12 her
daughter goes for a visit
to her father's
who by the way had recently remarried
and it was now married to a
psychotherapist
and she goes for the visit it never
returns
the girl announced out of nowhere that
she was trans and couldn't live with her
mother anymore because her mother's
disagreement with trans ideology made
her feel unsafe
now jeanette suspects and with good
reason i'm guessing
that the girl's psychotherapist stepmom
has a lot to do with her daughter's
discovery of her male identity
uh there's probably something to that
theory but but also
i'm sure she picked it up from school
she picked it up from social media
we've heard this story over and over and
over again
so many parents with this exact story
most of the time they're adolescent
girls but not always
girls perfectly fine
no signs of gender dysphoria at all no
indication ever at any point in her life
that she was confused about her gender
and then one day out of nowhere just
like that
she says oh i'm trans trans
now in this case the court ordered an
investigation of jeannette
to find out um if her daughter was
actually unsafe around her because
that's what the daughter said so they
they ordered an investigation
took seven months investigating this
mother
and found no abuse no neglect
but they did decide that jeannette needs
to quote further her understanding of
and support of the minor child as
relates to the minor child's gender
dysphoria
translation she's not on board with the
trans agenda and so she can't see her
daughter anymore
and she hasn't
she hasn't had any physical contact with
her child for the past three years
now eventually
and this is where it gets even more
sinister if that's possible
eventually she was forced to negotiate a
deal
right and here here was the deal that
she was given by the court
in exchange for giving up any legal
right to see her daughter again
she was assured in writing
that her daughter would not undergo a
medical transition without her
permission or a court order okay so this
is the deal with the devil that parents
are now forced to make give up your
rights to your daughter or we will
mutilate her we will cut her to pieces
if you don't give up your rights to her
imagine being a parent and having to
face that decision
and so she says well i guess i have no
choice i'm never going to see my
daughter again
but at least she won't be mutilated
but the thing is you know part of the
deal here is that even if you agree
uh with a court order we can still
mutilate her
and we know how easy it is to get the
court order
jeannette points out correctly that
murderers in prison now have more
communication and contact with their
children than she does
that kind of makes sense in a certain
way because as far as the system is
concerned she's worse than a murderer
i mean she's a transphobe
that's the cardinal sin
there's an interview on youtube that
janette did with the independent women's
forum worth watching she explains why
she rejects the idea that she should
simply have you know relented and
allowed her daughter to take the lead
and do whatever she wants here's what
she says about that
and what i have been told is to follow
her lead
to follow her in this journey
i am not willing to do that i don't
think that is good parenting it's my
responsibility
not to hook my boat to hers it is my
responsibility to be a lighthouse
to be something stable that she can see
some guide that she has that will always
be there that is consistent
i still do that today even though i have
no custody of her i have no medical
decision making no educational decision
making and no way to communicate with
her other than by mail
you know one thing you can see just
watching that video is i mentioned this
is a progressive democrat feminist the
mother is and you could tell just by
looking at her this is you know she
partially shaved head in the whole nine
yards
uh this is this and she talks about in
the article too in the interview how she
doesn't even she doesn't believe in
traditional gender roles so so
but but even then
not not good enough as far as the uh as
far as the far left radicals on the
court are concerned you know in in
family court as far as they're concerned
still not good enough
you you're progressive democrat
um everything else feminist
not good enough
your kid's still not safe
because there's this one item on the
progressive agenda that you do not go
along with
the imagery that she you know mentions
there of a lighthouse is quite powerful
and it's correct
if your child is lost in the fog of
confusion not sure which way is up not
able to discern east from west not sure
who they are
your job as a parent is to be a light
and a voice of of calm and clarity
it's not to abandon your child to the
mist and say hey just wander around in
whatever direction you want you'll
figure it out yeah whatever just go yeah
go that way it's fine
but that's the strategy the court
demands
turn the light off
leave your child to the dark
or else we'll take her from you they say
now um
sort of at the at the the end of this
story here at least up until this point
most recent development
is jeanette's daughter doesn't even
identify as trans anymore
okay so when so when she originally came
out as quote trans and her mother said i
don't buy it
she was right
she doesn't identify as trans anymore
she identifies as non-binary and uses
zee zerzer's
pronouns which means that this is
included too by the way we take your
kids away
affirm your daughter as a zur
whatever the hell that is or will take
her from you
of course if you're in this position as
a parent and you say it and you ask the
court what even is a zir like what does
that mean what do you ask what are you
telling me i have to do
i can't explain it it's total nonsense
but what does it mean for the girl it
means that she's grappling around
helplessly she's totally lost and
confused she has no idea who she is
but that's exactly what the groomers
want
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know dinner time is an incredibly
valuable moment to me personally because
i'm a gluttonous fat ass but it's also
valuable uh to my family all of us
dinner time is dedicated to shutting the
world out if only for an hour and being
present with my wife and kids hearing
about their day what they saw what they
learned the dinner table is where we
solve problems together as a family it's
where my wife and i strive to set a good
example for the kinds of men and women
our kids will grow up to be one of my
favorite ways to gather my family around
the dinner table is with good rangers
goodranchers cares deeply about
providing families with high quality
meat at a reasonable price their mission
is to bring people to the table making
those shared moments with your loved
ones easy accessible and delicious good
rancher ships 100 american meat born
raised and harvested in the u.s right to
your door plus when you subscribe your
price is locked in for the life of your
subscription good ranchers not only
supports american agriculture they're
also
big fans of the daily wire they support
all of our shows it's all the more
reason to support them so use my code
walsh for 30 off plus free shipping on
your first order take advantage of this
offer today invest in time share with
your family you're going to buy meat
anyway why not buy great meat from folks
who support all that we do here go to
goodranchers.com walls to start bringing
people back to the table and eating
seriously delicious
food you know one other thing about this
when you hear stories like this that's
why it's so
important
uh
to preserve your marriage
you know to fight tooth and nail to
preserve your marriage and
now it takes two to tango and so that
doesn't mean you know if if you're in a
marriage and you're fighting tooth and
nail and the other person isn't
and they just leave and they want to
blow the whole thing up there's only so
much you can do so i understand that but
going into a marriage to have the
agreement between both of the
understanding that we are going to fight
for this
uh this is one of the reasons why it's
so important because when when when the
the marriage falls apart
you're at the mercy of the courts you're
at the mercy of so many institutions
and the courts can come in and just say
that uh you know
whichever of you will be on board with
our ideological agenda we'll give the
kids to you
now as we've seen i mentioned the case
in ohio in 2018
even if you stay together and you still
are married the courts can still come in
and take your kid from you
it's a lot easier for them if you're
divorced
and you're already at each other's
throats and there's already an
antagonistic relationship
then it's a lot easier
and that's also why you know going into
a marriage
now like 10 even 10 years ago it's
unthinkable that you have to that you
that this is a question you have to ask
someone uh when when you meet them
you're in a relationship you're thinking
about the future
you know when i met my wife i did we
in the early going didn't talk about
this because it just didn't come up
but now
you know if i was single today
and
looking to get married
and i find someone i think this is this
is a this is someone who you know there
could be a serious relationship i'm
gonna ask them about this on the first
date
if you're a single person today you
should ask on the first date about this
trans stuff
i'm not saying it's the first thing you
bring up when you sit down for dinner
but i would bring it up
very very early on
you need to know
does this other person
believe that biology exists
do they understand that men are men and
women are women
do they do they think that children can
choose their gender yes or no
i would ask that question on the first
date because if they say if you get
anything but
a total affirmation of reality
and when you bring up you know
transitioning kids if they do anything
but scoff at it in horror and say that
it's barbaric and insane anything
outside of that and and you i just get
up from the table get up from dinner and
walk away say this isn't going to work
i don't care what else is going on i
don't care you know how if you're a nice
person doesn't matter this is not going
to work
because i can't see you're you're in
i'm in i'm living in the the universe
that we all occupy called reality you're
off of fantasyland and so we there's no
way to have a relationship certainly not
a marriage
where only one person in this couple is
in reality
all right
speaking of someone who's often
in some other reality joe biden
yesterday gave a speech where he was
talking about january 6th and you know
the the democratic party they were so
proud of this moment from joe biden that
they posted it they took this clip or
about to play for you and they put it on
the official twitter account for the
democrat party
because i guess this is supposed to be a
moment of joe biden being strong and in
command and coherent
but you tell me if that's what you see
watch
this you can't be pro-insurrection and
pro-cop you can't be pro-insurrection
and pro-democracy you can't be
pro-insurrection and pro-american donald
trump lacked the courage to act
the brave women and men in blue all
across this nation
should never forget that
now even for that
20-second clip
in which by the way he never blinks
you want you try to do that try try to
have you ever had a staring contest with
someone it's hard to get to 20 seconds
try try to make it 20 seconds
without blinking it doesn't blink at all
and i don't know if they have his
eyelids taped back or something i don't
know what it is but it doesn't blink
and uh they even in that 20 seconds they
got a cut there's a lot of jump cuts
they're cutting around all over the
place just to be able to string that
together and it is still
really disturbing
to see this guy he doesn't even
not blinking this totally vacant look in
his eyes
and i've been pointing this out about
joe biden
since the campaign and before that
you take everything else out of it
the fact that he's wandering around
tripping falling off of bicycles
babbling incoherently all the takings
they get all that out of it you can just
tell by looking in his eyes that it's
just not all there
these these black
sort of
doll like vacant eyes
he looks like an actual puppet at this
point i mean he looks like i'm half
expecting to see jeff dunham standing
next to him
he looks like a ventriloquist
dummy they've obviously got him hopped
up on all kinds of drugs i don't know
what they've got him on
and that's the best that's that's like
him at his best which is why they put
that up on uh on
on twitter
and by the way
what he's saying there also doesn't make
any sense let's just remember that let's
not get caught up in the fact that he's
senile and forget that what is being
said like the words that he's reading
don't make any sense at all
you can't be pro-insurrection and
pro-america
okay so first of all january 6 once
again was not an insurrection was not an
organized serious attempt to overthrow
the government uh
the only people that were armed on
january 6th
were the capital police officers who
shot and killed someone so that's that's
the only only only person who died as a
result of violence on january 6 was
ashley babbitt
who was uh one of the writers who was
shot and killed so that's the first
thing and the second thing is that so so
putting that putting january 6 to this
side which was not an insurrection it
was a riot
and uh it was a very stupid and foolish
event but it was not an insurrection
so tabling that okay
let's just
for a second dissect this idea that you
can't be pro-insurrection and
pro-america
america
was
founded
by insurrectionists it was literally
born in an insurrection
the insurrection is a violent overthrow
of a government
that's what happened that's what we
celebrate on july 4th
okay we have insurrectionists on our
money we build statues to them we name
cities after them
and i mean increasingly we're taking the
statues away and taking their names off
but it's not because of the insurrection
part
so it doesn't make it it's like saying
it's like saying that you can't be pro
flour and pro bread it's like this is an
ingredient a central
ingredient in what made america
just as a historical fact
um and and it is it is it is actually
relevant because this is not this is not
semantics here
it's not like an easy gotcha thing
america was born in insurrection
now
does that mean that we should be
pro-insurrection
well no because the statement doesn't
make any sense pro-insurrection
anti-insurrection what are you talking
about
obviously your opinion about an
insurrection
will be determined by the circumstances
of the insurrection right would anyone
so we hear from biden and from the left
now that wow
anti-insurrection really say
you think that there is never
a circumstance
were it where it would be morally
acceptable to violently overthrow a
government never it's like never
happened there's never been a government
that uh that ought to have been or was
justifiably overthrown you don't believe
that of course you don't believe that
once again if you believe that then you
then then america shouldn't exist to
begin with
so
that's that's
what's your what's your opinion on
insurrections i don't know can you tell
me like what's the what are we talking
about which insurrection which
government's being overthrown why are
they being overthrown
did the insurrectionists have any other
option but to resort to violence like
all these things need to be explained
before i can tell you whether or not i
think they did the right thing
just uh
totally ridiculous
okay
let's go to this
related here's a 2024 new hampshire
democratic primary poll which has been
released it's pretty early but
this is the polling data
and
this is this is great this is great
comedy right here this look at this this
is how bad it is for the democrats
if i'm a democrat i'm looking at that i
am panicking right now
and they are panicking so let's just
review keep this up because i want to
review the state of things
the guy who's currently president
okay our ventriloquist dummy in chief is
at just 16 and he's not in first place
he's behind his secretary of
transportation who lost to him in 20 in
the 2020 primaries and who is most
widely known for taking an extended
maternity break in the middle of a
supply chain crisis he's he's number one
at 17
then right below these two is an elderly
socialist woman best known for
pretending to be a comanche warlord
um and she's not even the only elderly
socialist on the docket the other is
pulling at eight percent behind
klobuchar
who isn't known for anything except uh
pummeling her staff
and speaking of pummeling staff kamala
harris comes in at six percent
as the vice president barely above the
big booty latina casio cortez
who most recently pretended to be
handcuffed
and speaking of being handcuffed she
barely edges out notorious crime lord
hillary clinton who's above stacey
abrams
a woman who's been wandering across the
countryside for three years
claiming to be the governor of georgia
and at dead last as always is cory
booker of course
this is
this is what they're facing this is
their whole roster
it is not a good situation
and uh you know it's not good when
you know high-profile democrat
politicians are asked
whether they think the current democrat
president should run again and they
don't want to talk about it so corey
bush
member of the squad was
was asked for her opinion does she think
not not like will he run again not not
asking for her prediction of the future
but should he run again
and um she wouldn't she wouldn't answer
the question which is certainly a way of
answering it but let's listen to that
you want to see joe biden run for a
second term she's going to go yeah i you
know that's an easy question that's not
going to take long do you want to see
joe i don't want to answer that question
because we have not that's not yet i
don't want to answer that question okay
um i mean he's the president he has the
right to to run for a second term
absolutely
but i don't want to i don't i don't want
i'd rather you not do that you got like
two minutes
yeah i know i got to get to the well
thanks very much 17. i appreciate it
uh i got to get to the uh i got to get
to the other thing that i got
i yeah i don't i don't have time to
answer that question
it's a yes or no question i just don't
have time i gotta i gotta run
that's bad news okay i mean that's like
it's like if you're married and you ask
your wife if she loves you and she says
uh do i love you well i don't really we
don't have time to talk about that i
gotta get to the other thing i got this
i gotta i gotta go do some laundry
not a good sign
um speaking by the way of the i guess
the front runner the democrat from front
runner pete budage he had some thoughts
uh recently he was on state of the union
on cnn and he had some thoughts about
the republicans
who do not favor federally codifying the
redefinition of marriage now there are
plenty of republicans as we saw in the
house that were on board with it
but uh but that but the majority still
were not and pete budage is very
offended and personally hurt by that and
here he is explaining why
this is really really important to a lot
of people
it's certainly important to me i started
my day as i try to do on weekends i try
to give chastain a little bit of a break
and
do breakfast with with both of our our
twins and
that alone that's no small thing as
every parent of small kids knows uh it
was one of those days where the tray
table wasn't quite
fitting into the high chair and uh i'm
trying to make sure that they're busy
enough with their little cereal puffs to
give me enough time to
chop up the banana and get the formula
ready and and it just
i don't know that half hour my morning
had me thinking about how much i depend
on and count on my spouse
every day and our marriage deserves to
be treated equally and i don't know why
this would be hard
for a senator
or a congressman i don't understand
how such a majority of house republicans
voted no
on our marriage on as recently as
tuesday hours after i was in a room with
a lot of them talking about
transportation policy having what i
thought were perfectly normal
conversations with with many of them on
that subject only for them to go around
the corner and say that uh that my
marriage doesn't deserve to continue if
they don't want to spend a lot of time
on this
they can vote yes and move on and that
would be
really reassuring for a lot of families
around america including mine
a couple things here first of all this
guy's such an egomaniac i mean they all
are but especially this guy and it's
even more grating with him because he
has there's just no
basis for it for his ego like it has
nothing to rest on no accomplishments to
rest on at all it's like a small town
mayor who runs for president fails
spectacularly then then he's given a an
appointment
you know a cabinet appointment for for
for no reason other than the fact that
he checks a couple of identity boxes
and uh and so that's it he's a
transportation secretary but he says oh
they voted on my marriage no they
weren't voting on your marriage you
egomaniac that's not what the vote was
there wasn't there wasn't a a a bill on
the docket what what do you think of
pete budage's marriage
no specifically it's about the should
the federal government
redefine marriage
should we codify
the redefinition of marriage on a
federal level that was the question that
they were answering and some of them
said no as they should have said
and by the way
the people who answer no to that well
there's there's a number of reasons why
you might answer no specifically to the
question of should the federal
government codified
but for the people who are
critics
of the whole uh you know
of the redefinition of marriage on any
level
they're not saying that your marriage
doesn't deserve to continue
what they're saying
is that your marriage
can't exist
because marriage is a particular thing
and your relationship
does not fall into that category that's
the argument now i realize that's still
going to offend you and make you upset
but that is the argument
and it's actually a really important
distinction
as i tried to explain last week and as
many people have attempted to explain
this is all a question of definition
and the idea for thousands of years is
that marriage by definition
is an in-principle procreative union
between a man and a woman
and it serves as the foundation of the
family which serves as the foundation of
human society that that was the answer
that was the definition that's what it
was
that's it
and then people like pete budojich came
along and said well it's not that
anymore and then the question in
response has always been well then what
is it if it's not that
pete boujee hasn't answered that
question
he says well my marriage deserves to be
treated equal to to other marriages well
but but but equal means the same
pete and is it the same
is
your relationship
with jason
is it the same as it is it in principle
in its substance
in its function
is it the same as my relationship with
my wife and the answer is no because my
relationship with my wife
has the potential to create new human
beings
and yours doesn't so
that is a difference
right that's a difference we can all
agree no question about that's a
difference
is it is it an important difference is
it a definitional difference
i would say
absolutely it is
of course it is
but even putting all that to the side
you know he's he says that well how how
could how could we talk about
they they would sit and talk about
transportation policy with me and then
and then go and vote the way they did
why should so what so they can't talk
about you cannot have
a productive conversation about
transportation policy with someone
unless they agree with your definition
of marriage
unless they affirm
your relationship as a marriage you
can't talk to them about transportation
policy see that's your problem that's
your hang up it's not theirs
i guess for those republicans they
figured yeah okay well i might not agree
with this but we can still talk about
transportation why can't we
you're the one who sets down kind of the
ground rules here and says well you have
to agree with everything about my
lifestyle or we can't talk about
anything
that's your problem
that that's that's uh that's you
deciding to do that
all right
on the on the subject of marriage here's
one other thing i want to mention this
from media it says
politico flagged a stunning poll result
showing that a quarter of republican
voters opposed congress passing a
federal law to protect interracial
marriage
supreme court justice clarence thomas
raised alarm bells over rights like
marriage equality access to
contraception and private sexual
activity with the supreme court
effectively overturned roe v wade uh et
cetera and so forth yada yada in the
latest edition of the political playbook
pm newsletter the authors noted that
they pulled the
act in political morning consult poll
and singled out several of his arts
results including this response to the
question do you support or oppose
congress passing a federal law to
protect the right to interracial
marriage
and uh 71 of the voters supported it
with just 15 opposing
and this is uh this is like the shocking
i can't believe
that that many americans would oppose
the bill
you know why they they probably oppose
it
not probably i'll tell you why they
oppose it
they oppose not interracial marriage but
the totally pointless
virtue signaling law that you're
proposing to protect
this this institution
that is not under any threat whatsoever
so what they're opposing is the virtue
signaling pointless law
that you want to pass
not not unlike the efforts to uh make
lynching illegal right just recently
passed
it's a hate crime to lynch someone
well i oppose that bill and every
republican should have opposed it
not because we support lynching people
but because it's already illegal
and there is nobody who wants to
legalize it
so this law serves no purpose whatsoever
it's already illegal it's already a hate
crime so no reason to do this you're
just doing it for virtue signal reasons
and i'm not gonna i'm not going along
with that you're you're treating passing
laws as a it's like a pageant it's a
stunt
i don't support that
so just to clarify
uh speaking of stunts and pageants the
here's a vogue vogue did a cover story
to photo shoot of the zelenski's in
ukraine and uh before we get to the to
the photos before we get to the photos
is a little bit from the article it says
there is no script for first ladies in
wartime and so elena zielenski is
writing her own the wife of ukrainian
present uh vladimir voldemir zelansky a
longtime comedy writer always preferred
to stay behind the scenes while her
husband a comedian turned politician
whose presidency may yet determine the
fate of the free world
glowed in the limelight but ever since
russia invaded ukraine on february 24th
zelenska okay well that's last name
zolenska has suddenly found herself
center stage in a tragedy
and then uh it goes on for a while from
there and okay we could see so uh annie
leibovitz
was on hand to and you know she was the
one the famous photographer photographs
all the celebrities and everything and
so she did let's go through some of
these photos they see that you see them
there uh
the two zelensky's
posing for all these different
photographs
looking very serious he's got his
trademark green t-shirt on the whole
time
but there she is i guess out on the
battlefield in a pretty blue jacket
because this is what you do right
this is what you do when you're in a war
and you're fighting for the fate of the
free world as we're told in the in the
profile there
you
you stop to do a magazine photo shoot
that's just standard procedure i mean
there are so many examples from history
of that right i mean i can't think of
any but i'm sure there are
we're still told that the war in ukraine
is a fight for the fate of the free
world it is a war for the fate of the
free world
and yet you've got
celebrities going over there you've got
all kinds of media outlets showing up
uh
photo shoots vogue is there doing a
cover story
fighting for the fate of the free world
but you have time to pose for um
for a photo spread
nothing nothing weird or off about that
at all right makes perfect sense
speaking of fighting for the fate of the
free world well not just for the fate of
the free world but actually for all life
on earth that's that's that's something
else that's happening right now there is
a fate there is a struggle for life
itself
for all life on earth
and here's uh bill ware of cnn
on cnn fretting about the fate of life
on earth and uh talking about how the
biden administration
needs to save all life on earth let's
listen
so where does that leave things right i
mean we have more than 35 million
americans they're under heat alerts this
morning i don't want you to do a deep
dive on on how climate change has has
created the conditions for a lot of
these things that we're seeing in a
number of fronts but
what can the administration do next i
mean because they may very well lose the
house or the senate in in several months
time
uh yeah what should folks look for
i mean that's that is the big question
that the president says his lawyers are
working on right now to what extent they
can stretch his executive powers without
any legislative help uh it's interesting
that the letter from staffers part of
their plea is please get joe manchin to
change his mind you know this is this is
hung up on an old-fashioned filibuster
sort of recent made up american rules
where the fate of life on earth is at
stake and and does it doesn't seem to
match now if this were fdr if this were
the 40s if this was after pearl harbor
okay there you heard it there that's the
line the fate of life
on earth
um
just think about the claim
this claim that's being made
you know like not only is climate change
happening well as established everyone
agrees that climate change is happening
everyone agrees no one denies that the
climate exists no one denies the climate
is changing that's what climates do
that's what climates do it's why we call
them a climate right
um so so you know no one's denying that
and
the claim though is that human activity
is affecting the climate
uh to such a degree that it's an
apocalyptic situation
and we're all going to die because of it
so that's one level of the claim but
then the next level is that
by just passing a law like that there is
actually a piece of legislation
that could be written and passed
that would fix the weather
and save all life on earth
and if not legislation then executive
action
this is what they're saying that there
is potential there is a
there is something that joe biden could
write down and sign
which would through the force
of that act
change the weather
and save all life on earth
i mean even if you even if you were to
buy everything the climate alarmists say
up to that point
even if you're with them on everything
else
maybe you even agree that we're all
going to die soon because of climate
change
it still should seem absurd to you that
there is a law that could be passed that
would fix any of this
all right one other thing i wanted to uh
mention a little bit of entertainment
news marvel has released a trailer for
the black panther sequel which is being
called wakanda forever and i'm not going
to play the trailer for you or anything
this begins now as i understand it i
think this is phase 5 of the marvel
franchise
multiverse whatever rollout and it just
continues on forever
i bring this up only to segway into
something else
as i mentioned before i'm a big fan of
books about survival and exploration so
i just read another one i just finished
a book called
the in the kingdom of ice
and which was written
by i believe the author hampton sides
written a few years ago
and it's a tremendous book and it tells
an incredible story about the uss
jeanette expedition
back in like the you know late 1870s
early 1880s and this was an expedition
that was meant to
go to the north pole
you know to and and to sail across it
across the open polar sea which doesn't
really exist but they didn't know that
at the time and so they were trying to
find this polar sea
and um this expedition well they never
make it to the policy which doesn't
exist they get locked in the ice
and they're trapped in the ice for two
years
up in the arctic just like
floating on the ice for two years on
this ship right
and which means they pass through two
arctic winters where it's 180 days of
darkness and they're just on this ship
and then finally the ice melts a little
bit and they they think that they're
going to escape and they're home free
but then they hit more ice and the boat
the ship sinks okay now they all have to
evacuate the ship and now they're
stranded on ice
in the middle of the arctic and they
have to make it a thousand miles to
solid land which is siberia so they have
to they have to traverse the ice for a
thousand miles to make it to siberia
which of course is a wilderness and they
gotta they're they're
carrying these boats the whole way
they're kind of like pulling these boats
because there are patches of of water
they have to sail across and it's just
this tremendously they finally make it
to um
siberia a bunch of them die along the
way and then they're in the wilderness
and then a bunch of them die in the
wilderness and like finally a few
survival survivors are able to find you
know some villages of uh of natives
there and uh and then they make it home
and they tell the story anyway the point
is
when i read books like this it just
reminds me
how much superhero franchises and
woke-ism together have totally ruined
hollywood
because you've got these real-life
stories that would make incredible films
but there's there's no one to make them
in hollywood
there should be
i mean the story that i just
butchered as i as i paraphrased it in
three sentences
how is there not
five movies about just that story there
should be 20 great films about arctic
exploration alone
and there's so many fantastic tragic
almost unbelievable stories but they're
not told and the reason they're not told
is that number one
the heroes are all men and mostly white
so that's one reason
and the other reason is that spider-man
never shows up
and so instead we just get the same damn
movies over and over and over again
while there are all of these
spectacular stories to be told of things
that really happened
and that and that most people today
don't know about and kids don't know
about because they're not hearing about
it in school
and so they don't hear about it at all
it is a it's a damned tragedy is what
i'm saying all the more reason
to stop watching the stupid superhero
movies you have to let them get like the
people that are making you have to let
them know we're sick of this we've seen
it
give us something better
you keep watching it they're not going
to ever stop
really do you really think black panther
2
is that a more worthy story to tell than
the story of the uss jeanette
men trapped on the ice traversing a
thousand miles go to siberia
survival tragedy all of that
black panther two is a better story
really
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
sophia says i really needed to hear that
stuff about marriage i love my boyfriend
so much and we're compatible but i tend
to overthink things way too much well if
you love them you're compatible if you
have if you have values alignment okay
so hopefully you've had that
conversation by now
and um and definitely ask him about the
trans stuff all of that
lines up then yeah just get married just
just get married what are you waiting
for
sophia uh pretty in pink says i was on i
was an only child and i was a handful
when you have no siblings to play with
you have to entertain yourself i think i
would have matured quicker if i had a
sibling i hope to have at least two one
day as soon as i find a man who is a
matt walsh fan uh well that's yeah
that's the other thing you should be
asking so that's another litmus test i
would ask on the first date
are you matt welsh fan are you a member
this week baby gang
um
yeah we're actually discovering this
right now you know having just as i
mentioned yesterday how we have just the
two-year-old at home right now the other
kids are with their grandparents
so we have we're you know we we're a
family with an only child just for the
week
and uh we are realizing what an
advantage it is to have other kids who
can play with her and entertain her
because if you don't have any of that
then it's like then then it's on us all
the time of course the trade-off is that
uh when you have other kids they also
antagonize each other and fight all the
time but it balances out i guess
and the other thing i got to get used to
is that even though our two-year-old is
pretty loud and she talks a lot still
there is there's there's this
comparative silence in the house that's
that's um when you're a parent with a
bunch of kids it becomes silence becomes
very unsettling you crave silence but
you're also this is the curse i guess
it's like you you crave silence because
you get so little of it but then when
you get it it's disturbing
because you know what silence usually
means when there's a like if there's a
moment of silence when you've all the
kids at home you know that something
terrible is happening
and so i've had to get used to that also
um
blue says matt i want you to know that
what you talked about towards the end of
the video right before the comment
section part you need to continue
hammering that point home as a 29 year
old single guy myself and with no family
and never had a father it kind of
sparked something having a man i respect
tell me to go have an adventure and live
in my car
honestly just hearing that it's okay and
i shouldn't worry and i can go anywhere
i want never really would have thought
about it like that but i guess i could
go anywhere in the world and do anything
i want if i really wanted to
uh yeah and it's by the way it's i'm not
saying that you should go out
and live in your car on purpose like
that you should seek that what i'm
saying is that
if you are a young a young able-bodied
man and you have no dependence and you
have no one who's who's relying on you
then the stakes are pretty low for you
and um
and you have a much better you have a
much greater ability to survive and
adapt than you realize it's just that
we
living in modern society we we
oftentimes never test it we never test
our ability to survive because we're not
we're not going to be going on
expeditions to the arctic or where it
really is tested
and so you just spend all your time at
home and you're watching a lot of tv and
you're living in luxury and comfort
and um
and maybe you crave adventure at some
level as all men do like at some level
you still crave it but you think that
there's no way you wouldn't be able to
survive out there in the wild world
but you can you just have to test
yourself
and that is the beautiful thing and if i
can if i can convince even one
guy to make one young man to make this
decision then i think it's a success
you can really go anywhere take
advantage of that
go anywhere
do anything just just have an adventure
it'll it'll be okay
i mean you might
you know you're gonna be making some
sacrifices you're not gonna be as
comfortable
even if you're not living in your car
right you're going to be
depending on yourself and you're going
to be taking care of yourself so
you know probably you're going to end up
in just some dumpy little apartment and
you're not going to be as comfortable
you're not going to have all the
luxuries you're used to
but it's
exciting to go and build a life for
yourself
be your own man
um
there's my there's my motivational
speech for the day another one so you
get two in two days we're on a roll here
as you're all aware no one can define
the word woman as of about five minutes
ago the people in my documentary what is
a woman legislator supreme court
appointees you name it no one can define
it as we talked about last week
merriam-webster redefined female in the
hopes that they could stuff it down the
memory hall without anyone noticing and
frankly this is the most attention a
dictionary is getting in the history of
etymology probably with all that in mind
we've decided to enlist the help of a
team of biologists to create a garment
in a lab and what we came up with is the
definition of woman t-shirt it's here to
educate all of those confused
individuals by emblazoning your chest
with the proper non-circular definition
of the word woman head over to my swag
shack dailywire.com
shop to purchase this shirt and see all
the other amazing products that we have
to offer today also
is it ironic to make an ad for an
ad-free viewing experience maybe but
that's exactly the type of experience
you'll get when you subscribe to daily
wire plus this is our growing hub for
all things daily wire where you'll find
shows podcasts like this one movies
bonus content and coming soon kids
content as well daily wire plus is
everything you love about daily wire
plus so much more and minus the ads go
to dailywireplus.com to become a member
today and get 35 off your new membership
that's
dailywireplus.com now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
you know there
might be some hope for camila harris
politically
if she could manage to stake out
something close to the middle ground
right positioning herself as a rational
centrist now she'd still have to contend
with the obstacle of her abysmal
personality and the visceral revulsion
people experience when they hear her
speak but at least then she'd have some
shot at forming a real constituency
but the problem is that there is no
center there's no middle between the
right on one side and abject insanity on
the other and if there was
harris isn't looking for it anyway she's
scrambling ever to the left hoping to
achieve relevancy by appealing to the
smallest possible subset of degenerate
whack jobs
she's not alone of course this is the
political strategy of the entire
democrat party yesterday harris set a
new standard in that department during a
roundtable discussion with um
disability rights leaders meant to
commemorate the signing of the americans
with disabilities act
and here's how she
began
her remarks listen
i want to welcome these leaders for
coming in to have this very important
discussion
about some of the most pressing issues
of our time
i am pamela harris my pronouns are she
of her i'm a woman sitting at the table
wearing a blue suit
well that's outrageous how does she know
that she's a woman she's not a biologist
and how does she know that she's wearing
a suit
is she a fashion designer and how does
she know that she's sitting at a table
is she a carpenter
maybe so perhaps this woman has many
more skills and qualifications than i
thought which is a low bar to get over
as i thought she had none at all harris
would go on to babble incoherently as is
her custom
nobody knows exactly what she was trying
to say but we do know that whatever she
was saying it was impactful
the dog's decision and the
act of the united states supreme court
to take away
a constitutional right that had been
recognized
the people of america
will impact a lot of people
and differently in some situations and
we need to be
responsive
to these issues and also lift up the
voices of all people who will be
impacted and the way that people be
impacted
so that's why we are convened today
and
i will add a couple of points in terms
of the direct impact
that we anticipate there will be from
the dodge decision
on people with disabilities
many people will be impacted impactfully
in ways that
cause an impact
on those
impacted by the impact
she truly has a way with words you have
to admit and her way is to string them
together totally at random but camilla
wasn't the only person embarrassing
herself at this at this event all of the
speakers introduced themselves by
listing not only their pronouns but also
their race and their articles of
clothing
it was we can safely guess
the first time ever that a white house
meeting began this way
the dubai administration continues to
make history in all of the worst and
most humiliating ways possible let's
watch
thank you madam vice president
my my pronouns are she her i'm a white
woman with long brown hair i'm wearing
red
a red dress and i'm wearing a
see-through mask so you can see my red
lips i am a
black woman with curly hair and i am
wearing a vintage black and floral dress
uh i'm a latina
with blonde highlighted hair and i'm
wearing a gray blazer over a black
sheath dress
chyna looks on and laughs the entire
world laughs except for that part of the
world which suffers from the same
psychological maladies as us
now the ostensible reason for this whole
routine
is to be more inclusive of the visually
impaired
this is one of the latest most cutting
edge
innovations in the field of woke virtue
signaling it's even more advanced than
trans pride flags and land
acknowledgments the idea is that blind
people will feel more included more
involved if you provide a brief physical
description of yourself before speaking
but but this is obviously very stupid
for reasons
too numerous to count but we'll just go
through a partial list first of all
if a person was blind at birth
you're not helping them by mentioning
your blue suit they're not going to know
what blue is in fact if anything you've
only further alienated them by bringing
up a concept that has no meaning to them
this method of this method of
introduction then appeals to a portion
of the visually impaired a subset of the
subset
but while appealing to them it further
marginalizes everyone else in that
community
second does it actually appeal even to
that subset of the subset
are visually impaired people asking for
this
or would they prefer if you just got on
with saying whatever it is you want to
say and got it over with
and if they do want the physical
description is the color of your jacket
really what they're looking for
i mean like if you're visually impaired
someone's speaking and you don't know
what they look like and you're wondering
what they what they look like
are you wondering i wonder what color uh
shirt they're wearing
is that the information that you you you
need to form your mental picture
no why not mention your height
i want to mention your weight
like if it were me that's one of the
questions i would have if i couldn't see
and someone's talking like one of my
things is i'm wondering how tall are
they how fat are they just to just to
build that mental picture
why not provide a one to ten rating of
your physical attractiveness
these are the kinds of details that
people are actually interested in anyway
third does camila harris give her
pronouns and her selective physical
description every time she addresses an
audience
well no of course not
she did it in this case because it's a
round table about disabilities but
is that the only kind of conversation
that the visually impaired ought to be
included in
i mean isn't it all the more
marginalizing of the disabled community
to specifically include them in
conversations about being disabled but
not in every other kind of conversation
so by doing this what you're saying to
the visually impaired is oh yeah we
really need you to be included in this
conversation
but then this meeting's over and you go
off and you talk about something else
you say oh no we don't need you guys for
this this isn't about
we'll bring you back in when we're
talking about disabled stuff
how many visually impaired people were
even watching the vice presidential
roundtable discussion about the
americans with disabilities act
were any
and yet camilla harris only makes the
effort to be inclusive of the
differently abled during that event
that seems even more offensive to me
this is the problem with this kind of
virtue segment once you start doing it
you can never stop
because if you're saying that the whole
routine of identifying the color of your
jacket like you're a character in a book
for preschoolers if you're saying that's
necessary or important for the sake of
inclusivity then you have no excuse to
ever stop doing it
so you wanted to be inclusive of the
blind yesterday but not today what gives
this is the conundrum you make for
yourself
fourth speaking of being inclusive the
great irony
is that all of these women
were making a show of their visual
impairment inclusiveness while at the
same time
needlessly alienating and excluding the
hearing impaired
because as you notice if you watch the
clip they were they were signaling
virtue not only with pronouns and
physical descriptions but also by
wearing masks
but face masks marginalize those with
hearing difficulties and i say
marginalize in this case for once
not ironically or sarcastically
i mean the masks really do marginalize
people who have trouble hearing the
muffled voices the inability to read
lips
this has been a nightmare for the
hearing impaired i mean really it has
actually excluded we hear so much about
people being excluded it has actually
excluded people they can't tell what
anyone is saying
and and people with hearing difficulties
they've complained about this for years
about the masks trying to explain that
all of the unnecessary masking is
legitimately making it difficult for
them to function in society
and communicate with people
but the coveted cultists just ignored
them
and now even at a roundtable discussion
about disabilities
people who suffer from that rather
common disability are again ignored
but this is what virtue signaling is all
about it's done in the name of inclusion
and yet it always excludes
far more people than it includes
the the signals the virtue signals
target people at the intersections of
various identity groups and at the
intersection of the already intersected
groups becoming more and more acute and
specific until you've excluded almost
everyone
in the name of including a handful of
people who were already included and
really didn't need the special
accommodation
but that's okay to the virtue signaler
because
nothing that she's doing is actually for
that small group
see though all the stuff about you know
the including visual impaired people
that's not who it's for
no she's not worried about them
she's worried about herself
the point is to brand herself as one of
the enlightened
one of the progressive
one of the chosen
and thus as far as i'm concerned
i'm told for the fourth time
she is also now one of the canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomblin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor in chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode
whistleblowers come forward alleging a
scheme at the fbi to downplay derogatory
information on hunter biden
concern over monkey pox continues to
grow and the senate advances a
semiconductor chip bill amid a
technology race with china join us and
get the facts first on the news you need
to know with our show morning wire
[Music]